punto en común es un experimento social
que reúne a personas con creencias y
experiencias opuestas
recuerden consultar a expertos y ser
críticos al momento de formular una
opinión por favor la manida de cada
participante y como siempre sean
empáticos no estarán preparados la
invasión de rusia es toda una locura
pero qué opinan en realidad los
ucranianos y los rusos
punto en común
levanten la mano si están de acuerdo con
la frase
estoy orgulloso de mi país
siento que todo lo que estamos haciendo
es defendernos y lo hacemos lo mejor que
podemos estoy orgullosa de mi presidente
por no oír del país y también me
enorgullece en todos los ucranianos que
se han unido en el presente
nunca he tenido una percepción muy buena
o poco realista sobre mi país porque la
verdad es que mi familia atravesó por
una situación en la que sufrió mucho por
la corrupción este sigue siendo un gran
problema en ucrania pero este conflicto
en definitiva me ha hecho sentir más
orgullosa de los ucranianos bueno a mí
me interesa mucho escuchar a ser gay
hay algo que quiero explicar hay una
diferencia entre el estado y el país
para mí el estado es el que creó la
guerra mientras que el país refleja otra
realidad con las miles de personas que
salen a protestar a las calles de
ciudades como moscú o san petersburgo y
que corren el riesgo de ir a la cárcel
reciben palizas y otras van presas por
años el riesgo que corren es enorme pero
eso no impide que continúen luchando por
una causa como ésta y aunque no tengan
esperanza lo hacen de forma simbólica
para demostrar que están en contra de la
guerra y creo que casi todos los rusos
están en contra de ella el problema es
que tienen miedo están aislados y
amenazados y me siento orgulloso a pesar
de que el movimiento disidente sea un
caso partido pero esto es lo que eligió
toda la gente gracias por la explicación
la aprecio mucho y estoy de acuerdo con
lo que dijiste yo también apoyaré a las
personas en rusia que están en contra de
la guerra y que están al tanto de todo
lo que está ocurriendo con ucrania yo
los voy a apoyar gracias a aquellos que
no estuvieron de acuerdo con la
afirmación podrían intervenir ahora
si en mi caso estoy totalmente de
acuerdo con ser gay a mí no me
enorgullece el gobierno de mi país
tampoco me gustan sus acciones pero yo
sí estoy orgullosa de aquellas personas
de las que escucho las cuales son buenos
ciudadanos y también son un buen ejemplo
para este país no es por lo que ha
ocurrido este año si me hubieran
preguntado lo mismo digamos hace 15 años
yo
respondería igual no estoy orgulloso de
mi país rusia no se preocupa por la vida
de la persona promedio la verdad cuando
no todo el estilo de vida que tenemos
aquí en especial después de haber
viajado a otros lugares yo puedo decir
que no estoy orgulloso de mi país por
ejemplo mía me va a buscar es decir mi
abuela recibe una pensión que es mucho
menor que el salario mínimo y ella casi
no tiene dinero para sobrevivir por
supuesto rusia también tiene aspectos
positivos como su gente por ejemplo pero
si me preguntan
me gusta vivir aquí o no por el gobierno
yo diría que no sería irresponsable que
eeuu se involucrará más en la guerra
en
ucrania se dio todo el armamento nuclear
de su
el territorio hubo un acuerdo firmado
por eeuu y también rusia necesitábamos
una garantía de que nos protegerían en
caso de que algo como esto llegara a
pasar ahora hay una guerra pero ucrania
sigue pidiéndoles a los otros países
estas armas si tuviéramos medios para
protegernos cuando se presentara el caso
de una invasión podríamos protegernos
adecuadamente eeuu no puede ser un
espectador y de hecho no lo es ya que
como nación apoya a ucrania y así como a
la resistencia y en efecto sería
irresponsable que eeuu no se involucrará
en especial ahora con el estado de la
guerra yo comprendo la razón por la que
los soldados de la otan no están en
ucrania ya que eso podría generar un
conflicto muy fuerte con rusia así que
es entendible que nadie quiera
arriesgarse de ese modo cuando todos
conocemos a vladimir putin con sólo
pisar un botón puede hacer que todo el
mundo muera pero también estoy de
acuerdo con que sería irresponsable
y dejar las cosas de esta manera
aprovecharé para hacerles una pregunta
extra a alguno de ustedes le preocupa el
uso de las armas nucleares
no lo sé creo que es el poder que tiene
putin en el mundo yo creo que las
apariencias nos están engañando vemos
que los soldados de ucrania están
haciendo lo que pueden que son
excelentes defendiendo a su país pero
sigue habiendo escasez de armamento creo
que no solo se trata de las armas sino
de la ayuda humanitaria es necesario
enviar comida a las zonas que están bajo
ataque o han sido invadidas así que para
los soldados es peligroso porque podría
parecer una declaración de guerra de
otros países hacia rusia por eso creo
que no solo se deberían enviar armas
sino también insumos para las personas
afectadas en los territorios que han
sido invadidos los rusos no permiten el
acceso de ayuda humanitaria hay mucha
ayuda disponible para nosotros pero
ellos no la dejan pasar los soldados
matan a los civiles también a los
voluntarios y a cualquier persona que
quiere ayudar yo creo que usar
armamento y tomar medidas drásticas es
lo mejor a mí me preocupa mucho el hecho
de que
putin nos amenace con armas nucleares
porque ya hemos visto a los militares
rusos en su orilla y en chernóbil lo que
es muy peligroso y atemorizante yo creo
que puede ser un acto de intimidación
para asustarnos pero también hay que
recordar que meses antes de la guerra
putin trató de asustar a todo el mundo
diciendo que él daría inicio a una luego
prometió no hacerlo y aún así lo hizo
mi vida cambió desde que empezó la
guerra
de hecho mi vida al igual que la de casi
todos los ucranianos no cambio sino que
fue destruida
la noche del 24 de febrero y yo desperté
a causa de
la explosión así como por el sonido de
las bombas yo sólo tuve creo que
una hora para recoger todas las cosas
que necesitaba y ahora
sólo me queda empezar una nueva vida y
desde cero también tuve que dejar el
país sabía que no podría regresar a casa
pero tuve que empacar muy pocas cosas
todo paso demasiado rápido sólo quiero
volver y abrazar a mis padres yo
realmente deseo que ellos deje en
ucrania pero no quieren irse me preocupa
su bienestar yo no creo que la vida de
ninguno ucraniano sea igual que antes no
hay nada que pueda compararse con lo que
los ucranianos han tenido que enfrentar
y como sus vidas han cambiado sin
embargo muchas de las personas que son
de rusia han experimentado un gran
cambio en sus vidas aunque de otra
manera yo soy abogado y he trabajado en
casos contra rusia en el tribunal
europeo de los derechos humanos como
consecuencia directa de la guerra rusia
fue expulsada del consejo de europa y
ahora la litigación en el tribunal
europeo no tiene sentido gente
incluyéndome tuvo que dejar rusia en mi
caso elegirme del país porque no pienso
pagar ni un solo centavo de impuestos
allí puede ser poco pero es importante
para mí quiero decir que mi madre perdió
su trabajo y ella trabajaba en una
compañía internacional pero actualmente
no es posible transferir dinero a rusia
debido a las sanciones por esto yo no
pude encontrar muchos de los
medicamentos que necesito así que tuve
que ordenar algunos del exterior pero
mientras venían en camino no pude
medicarme mi novia es americana ella
solía ayudarme a pagar por las medicinas
pero ya no puede porque no es posible
para ella transferir me el dinero y por
mi cuenta no puedo pagarlas creo que los
ucranianos incluso aquellos que han
dejado el país no creo que se sientan
seguros supimos de casos como el de los
rusos que golpearon a un bartender en un
bar por el hecho de ser ucraniano y
también vimos la marcha a favor
la guerra en berlín tenemos que
encontrar un lugar para vivir es todo en
lo que pensamos no en cosas como qué voy
a hacer hoy sino dónde voy a dormir que
voy a comer en qué voy a trabajar mucha
gente se quedó indocumentada y ni
siquiera es posible obtener un pasaporte
internacional o hasta el ucraniano
porque la embajada no los ofrece tengo
un buen amigo que trató de escaparse de
ucrania por la frontera con rusia y en
uno de los puntos de control por el que
pasó un soldado ruso le pidió que le
diera sus zapatos como paga para poder
salir y por eso el ejército ruso no
tiene escapatoria porque una vez que
empiezan a merodear oa robar
descaradamente es todo nunca ganarán si
acción así con su gente todos tenemos
esta ilusión de que estamos viviendo en
una nueva era en un nuevo mundo donde
los derechos humanos son respetados
pero ahora nos damos cuenta de que esto
no es cierto y de que todo es incluso
peor que en el siglo pasado todo se
puede repetir y este es un fenómeno que
me hace sentir muy insegura yo vivo en
la ciudad de san petersburgo
desde que la guerra comenzó me ha
preocupado un poco el aspecto de mi
seguridad personal respecto a tener
problemas con la ley y la policía he
participado en algunas protestas también
he podido grabarlas y subir los vídeos a
mi canal de youtube vía mi tic toc y
durante este proceso tenía miedo de que
me pusieran una multa o me llevaran a
prisión
yo creo que acepté el hecho de que eso
pudiera ocurrir en algún punto dejaré
rusia yo regresé al país hace dos años y
de hecho planeo irme de nuevo dentro de
uno o dos años más y tal vez deba irme
un poco antes pero no planeaba hacerlo
ahora o también soy de san petersburgo y
creo que hay dos problemas uno que si
tienes problemas con la ley no podrá
salir del país será muy tarde y dos en
uno o dos años en mi opinión no tendrás
oportunidad de salir del país la
frontera cerrará la verdad es si
realmente quieres irte y se te presenta
la oportunidad
pero cuanto antes
yo soy inmune a la propaganda 3
creo que lo que hace la propaganda es
que a menudo ni siquiera se preocupa por
mostrarte la historia real detrás de los
hechos y solo quiere que la gente crea
en lo que se les dice en ocasiones
solo se inventan numerosas narrativas
para quizás crear esta impresión de que
no se puede confiar en nadie
en mi opinión esta es una táctica muy
poderosa suelo comparar la propaganda
con la comida rápida es de fácil acceso
no se consume rápido también te hace
feliz por un tiempo y por supuesto te
obsesionas con ella acaba con la duda de
la gente les ofrece una visión amplia de
las cosas lo cual es muy conveniente
pero la intriga que debería existir para
progresar e investigar es algo con lo
que también es difícil vivir a pesar de
sus efectos los que consumen la
propaganda de hecho quieren seguir
haciéndolo como pasa con la comida y ese
es el motivo por el que no creo ser
inmune a ninguna de las dos lamentable
tengo una pregunta para ustedes es
verdad que en rusia todos los canales de
televisión independientes cerraron a
horas y ya no tenemos canales o
independientes lo mismo ocurre con los
periódicos de hecho los únicos
periodistas que quedan en rusia son
corresponsales de guerra y cada vez
quedan menos y la única manera en que
puedes acceder a información que no esté
el estado es por internet y hay que ser
muy cuidadosos con eso y usar un bp.n
porque hay varios sitios que el gobierno
no sólo
cerró sino que prohibió en línea tengo
una amiga es de rusia y cuando todo esto
empezó ella sólo publicaba cosas buenas
sobre su vida saben así que un día yo le
pregunté por qué no publicaba sobre la
guerra en sus redes sociales y me dijo
soy alguien insignificante que podría
hacer y para mí esa es la peor respuesta
que podrías dar en un momento como este
porque en estos dos meses se ha
comprobado que la gente no está haciendo
nada yo creo
que incluso en las redes sociales
si todos expresamos nuestra opinión si
buscáramos hacernos escuchar podríamos
hacer que las cosas cambien hasta
podríamos hacer que organizaciones
importantes nos ayuden si decidimos no
quedarnos callados la guerra entre
ucrania y rusia era inevitable 3
no creo que hubiera una razón válida
para esta guerra sobre todo porque quien
la inició fue una persona si es una
persona que no ha encontrado ninguna
resistencia por años no creo que no haya
habido resistencia de hecho hay miles de
personas en rusia que están o estuvieron
en la cárcel por protestar contra él han
asesinado a periodistas por tratar de
decir la verdad hoy también ha habido
activistas que han sacado del país
detenido atacado o incluso asesinado así
que si ha habido resistencia pero ésta
no ha tenido éxito mis abuelos piensan
que es más que bueno que rusia se esté
defendiendo pero ellos no saben lo que
ocurre en verdad y como solo ven
televisión ellos no buscan noticias en
internet porque piensan que eso es malo
y que sólo hay información falsa y creo
que es necesario mostrarles hechos
reales a los rusos a todos nosotros
mejor dicho de esa forma habrá menos
personas que apoyen la guerra es más que
obvio que hay muchas personas que
no creen que lo que está pasando sea
real pero si eso es lo que opinan
entonces vengan porque no vienen a la
frontera porque no hacen eso debe ser
mucho más sencillo decir no pasa nada no
no no es tan fácil pensar que todo es
una mentira pero entonces porque no
vienen y lo comprueban por sí mismos
nadie lo quiere hacer yo creo que esta
guerra tendrá un ganador
en mi humilde opinión esta guerra no es
entre rusia y ucrania sino que es un
conflicto entre la dictadura
y la libertad y creo que por eso putting
decidió atacar a ucrania en resumen el
odia la democracia los derechos y la
libertad pero estoy convencido de que
esta democracia estos derechos y estas
libertades triunfarán y de forma curiosa
y un tanto irónica tal vez esto sea el
aspecto positivo de esta guerra es decir
el recordarle al resto de los países que
son libres lo que deberían valorar que
lo importante no es el gas natural que
obtienen de rusia sino las libertades y
la seguridad que cada país tiene y es
gracias a ucrania que podemos recordar
lo fácil que es perderlo todo a menos
que seamos capaces de defender nuestros
valores y principios por eso yo mantengo
la esperanza de que al final esto
represente una toma de conciencia para
todos los países libres para que sepan
por qué deben mantenerse unidos
protegerse y rechazar a los gobiernos
totalitarios
y realmente
espero que
triunfe la libertad tanto los ucranianos
como los rusos todas las personas
comunes tendrán numerosas pérdidas pero
si analizamos esto desde otra
perspectiva no se trata solo de rusia y
ucrania sino de temas más importantes
apuesto a que son haré un poco básica
pero igual lo diré no creo que nadie
gane en todo caso es cuestión de quien
se lleve el mayor daño y
ambas partes ya están muy mal y seguirán
recibiendo más daños pero me parece que
rusia es la que se verá más afectada por
el tiempo porque todo este aislamiento
no se detendrá si por obra de algún
milagro la guerra acabará mañana no creo
que este sea el fin del aislamiento que
se está enfrentando en rusia pero creo
que lo más grave es que la gente sigue
muriendo a diario
que en el caso de rusia esto no es algo
que esté ocurriendo solamente ahora sino
algo que el país viene arrastrando por
bastante tiempo y que lo sigue afectando
actualmente no hay ganadores en una
guerra en mi caso puedo decir que yo
también espero que triunfe la libertad y
que
podamos obtener algo bueno de todo esto
más adelante pero creo que las guerras
solo traen consecuencias y no ganadores
como tal habrá muchas más muertes muchas
personas sufrirán la economía se
desplomara y bueno puede que quizás a
largo plazo haya un ganador y puede que
haya ganancias
pero la cantidad de daños que toda
guerra genera es es demasiado quisiera
decir que todas las personas rusas a las
que conocí aquí tienen unos pensamientos
muy sano quizá alguien que esté a favor
de rusia pensará que este vídeo es una
propaganda para apoyar a ucrania
sorprender de que todos estemos de
acuerdo también deben saber que de eeuu
nos pagará miles de dólares por esto así
es si parece que todos pensamos igual